how much did you collaborate with the
designer on this look what you mean how
much I collaborate a girl
together yeah yeah yeah what do you kids
we'll say about this look I think my
kids are gonna love it my daughter's
gonna gag you always look forward to at
the Met Gala card to hit the red carpet
of course
I need you to be here tonight
I mean it's amazing you know like I've
spent so much money in Chanel like I
might as well be here always
yes I hope I hope I hope everybody made
him proud Casino like he's the type to
be like right he probably in heaven like
yes no yes but you nailed the assignment
tonight ah thank you we're looking
forward to hanging out with tonight uh
everybody everybody there there's on
that chill Vibe you know what I'm saying
anybody got an Etc and I have a headache
and I cannot drink with a headache
welcome to Kayla if you want tequila
that girl that's gonna make my hair
oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
Andrew this has gone better than any net
gal I've ever done
um
she's so funny
so let's let's do the railing let's do
the riser for her
[Applause]
[Music]